what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you've got inside
you explode out into the world to have a
big impact for you your family and the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're gonna learn from one of the
richest men in the world Carlos Slim
Helu and my take on his top ten rules
for success rule number two is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always guys as you're watching if you
hear something that really really
resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick for
yourself as well enjoy
have you had failures failures yes now
they what I say to my children that you
need to have failures but try to make
small failures as more mistakes our
autumn business and in life not to make
big mistakes you learn from mistakes
always and from the mistakes of the
others you need to learn old is more
important to learn of other mistakes
that make your mistakes to learn how
would you describe wealth
what is wealth to you well I think
wealth is a kind of instrument to create
welfare is a a instrument to create
welfare in a society I think this
different world than income regularly
well should we manage with efficiency so
principally that so pretty and create
more wealth it's like a tree a fruit
tree well it like a fruit tree you the
the product of the tree are the fruits
and this fruit should be is the income
that you need to give away but taking
part of these fruits to grow the more
trees more free is the wealth yes and
the fruit is the income don't you need
to create more wealth more fruits more
trees and to have a bigger production of
wealth and and of income
I believe that family and personal life
and business of a professional life is
not only compatible is necessary you
will have a better professional life
with a good personal life and family
life that if you don't have a good
personal life and
family life I think I don't know
understand the contrary and it's very
clear that that the good personal life
make you stronger you are stronger for
the challenges you are working I think I
don't believe in working 20 hours of 16
hours of 14 hours when you work too much
is because your job is beyond you you
are not controlling the you are not
doing good your job if you need to be 15
hours 16 hours is because you are not
organized then you don't have the
negation of your responsibilities and I
don't believe that in any business in
any activity you need to work 15 or 16
hours and you don't have time for
yourself or for your family for anyone
success is not being recognized by
others it is not about an external
opinion it is about an internal state of
being
it is the harmony between the soul and
our emotions that are felt by love
family friendship authenticity and
honesty the funda the fundamental and
permanent values that are far superior
to professional economical social or
political success would you say this is
baby tripe that you're a happy man well
I think happy is not a way to be but
they a way to go you want to be heard on
Oh No
it's a way of living of living is a way
of being and living and
I can't I cannot explain very well is
not the point is not that you're ripe to
one point and that you're happy now it's
a way to do things to live to to feel
that make you happy it's a goal if they
say no it's not a goal it's a way they
say direction you say a he'll say it's a
way to live
you either way that you live if you live
with the loving group life loving people
with the having challenges in life doing
things making things for for others and
you say I think that's what what is very
feed you on you started out as a young
person when you started amassing your
your businesses
did you set as a goal for yourself I
want to be that most successful business
management
I think businessman like painters or
artists or doctors they get involved
with his his activities and don't worry
about it's not a football game is is you
are doing what you think you should do
and you like to do Andrew working in the
activities I came like a newsman or like
a painter in what you are interested I
don't I am NOT concerned about what did
say and if it is true or it is not true
and I think any way that any privilege
that you have and as much as you have a
privilege is higher give
responsibilities I don't look for the
for being is not looking for for for
scores like in the school or the
competition
I think vocation motivation what you
study what you read what you learn and
especially to to organize a a team of
people
resource Human Resources now a team of
people that get motivated that what
would you that accept your leadership
and that you are constantly forming
hating and work without without without
with a motivation that make them feel
feel feel that they can achieve anything
that they propose and to feel to be part
of a of a win winner team Trufant a team
that is with that is true fund that can
win that is winning that motivated more
the people and that's the way you look
in sports is the same in politics is the
same in any in science why this team do
that why Barry Bonds is breaking this
record why he's making wise polemic
these things of Maradona because they
are wood with this vocation
they have talents but also they work
strongly they work not the number of
hours but in training and learning and
planning and creating do you like
competition sure
imagine that you are a outlet that runs
100 meters you will run alone
competition make you better
you need to have competition and also
the most important international
reference for whatever you do you know
you need to have the highest reference
to make you a good job we are in 18
countries 18 countries today and we have
competition everywhere I don't think
that there is now a telecommunication
service in any place I do not know Korea
not including North Korea that there is
no competition that's there's no
monopoly that until I understand there
is competition everywhere I think the
only way to finish with poverty is
giving good works so enabling people to
work as opposed to giving you stuff
that's why we are working in
creating human capital I think that the
business community compromised to go
beyond the business to help not to have
to to solve the social problems of our
countries getting involved with money
and with our time because it not a
problem of money I think that
businessman and entrepreneurs have more
experience managing resources and we can
solve more easily the problems that
politicians that have other views they
are thinking an election that year
ticking popularity they are thinking in
some other things and I don't think that
giving money should be something for
popularity personal popularity let's say
how we give money that we are populist
because we're giving everyone that's not
the way you need to put your money but
put more you do work you do your time
yeah we're solving the problem because
we think is the solution what I want to
do though is that things make things
change that my family follow this work
not follow they are doing the work more
than me and that my grandchildren also
follow followed working for that and
that in some years thinks in our
country's change I think that also by
all means is very important to to finish
with poverty to fight poverty is good
economically in the past was from
something ethical and moral like what
they are talking about giving money
morality and ethically what we need is
effectiveness and now to take out poor
people from poverty and to put them in
the modern economy is very good for the
economy for the country for the society
and for the business is the best
investment what scares you
that's crazy I think to live with fear
is the worst feeling that human beings
had can have as I tried not to have
these feelings I don't make a masochist
breathing or looking what can be
negative do you get down sometimes you
get a little down and then you wait up
faster and stronger
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Yogesh 85 d
asked me to if there's something you'd
like me to cover in a future top 10
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote I'd also love
to know what did you learn from this
video what lesson really hit home the
hardest what are you going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
or to your business leave it down the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Peter Joseph's arc of the
3rd thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word taking
that picture in your car post it online
I really appreciate the support and I'm
so glad you enjoyed the read thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
was your goal to make money no I think
that the one that just like that like a
goal not you go no no I think that's why
there are so much financial Rambo's of
gamblers gambling trying to bet to win a
lot one that's a kind of gambling more
than other thing when they want to win
only if you're in business you need to
understand the environment you need to
have a vision of future and for that you
need to know the past and it's very
important from this side like a
businessman but also in the personal
side the businessman cannot be only
business you need to have more interests
life offer a lot of interest
many things to know to learn to feel to
live your gift
do you think it's a gift the ability to
just do business well you succeeded in
so many things you think you born with
that I think always you see combination
of genetics or born like sports like you
like a any activity you have a
combination of born with that and an
education and training and work etc
experience circumstances you have a
nappy but you love business right
you don't you like I love to I love to
invest and to create economic activity
when you you you can read a balance
sheet
[Music]
or ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]